and uh i knew you when you were fat you
know what i'm saying and now you know
thanks
very much
you were hacky and fat
like oh well that's even more
unnecessary
your business
hey bro hey bro
hey hey yo i asked uh i asked my boys i
asked my quick little sidebar i asked my
boy cause i'm i'm in five four three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast we have the man here himself my
man grew out his fro nice and curly you
look like jada pinkett smith in the
early days i love it
sexy as hell toxic though
toxic
so we got to update everybody on your
whole life because you had the studio
out in houston which was popping it was
super [ __ ] dope yeah and it's gone
out of nowhere i saw this post that says
no more man legendary right
this was just be dropping bombs on
people out of nowhere no heads up just
like we closed it i tell you what i
didn't know we're closing either bro
yeah man i uh i'm back you know what i'm
saying i'm chris sosa by the way almost
you get you gave me the the fro the the
fro took over right oh that's right this
is this is uh chris
christino socino
oh that's a nice one i like it cristino
socino yeah i love it all right i'll put
it hey yo so uh but yeah man i was in
houston for two years it went so quick
bro it's crazy that it was two it's kind
of insane because of what pandemic did
because it feels like you left like
yesterday and now you're back here
immediately
yeah bro it's wild i was i was out there
i went out there 2020 my brother
convinced me uh to make the move uh it
just made sense you know i was still
making i could make money from anywhere
because i you know working online
creating content producing and stuff
over at all deaf and uh yeah i was at
home i was up back home i'm from houston
and so i was back home and with the fam
uh i got nephews so i was theo mode you
know
and uh uh this studio this opportunity
just like fell on my lap you know what i
mean like this building that said lease
on it and i called the number and uh uh
the the numbers and everything when i
when i found out all the numbers i was
paying i was paying more for one bedroom
out here
than what that was you know over there
so uh i learned so much about you know
contractors and build outs and uh uh the
lumber lumber's going up you know
expanding yeah lumber is yeah yeah for
sure apparently we don't have trees
anymore
the trees don't exist anymore straight
up bro they figured it out bro they they
basically put supreme on all the trees
it's crazy because they're like oh we
don't have any more beef now beef prices
are going out but it's like what the
[ __ ] does that have to do with trees
they just figured out bro that they just
they just made everything one of one
[Laughter]
you know there's only one tree it's the
only one we gotta split it with the
whole world
pic pictures wisely but uh but yeah man
it was just uh we i i honestly man like
it was it was like the dopest experience
bro and i created some dope uh uh
moments and and like i know it impacted
a bunch of people man a lot of people
who came in to my building it was always
like uh
everybody was always just kind of
looking at the walls and the lighting
people a lot of people complimented the
lighting of how i set it up and uh it
was it was it was a lot of fun you know
and then
it was february february 1st i get hit
up by issa rae
oh [ __ ] she emails me and uh she's like
hey i was uh casually talking up to
about you to my the head of my uh
management company color creative and uh
you know i
was talking about how talented you are
and and she asked if i could introduce
you all is that cool and i'm like
of course yeah
yeah are you asking absolutely yeah yeah
this is really cool about those she's
always would ask like hey is it okay if
i give you a role in my show i'm like
what do you mean of course yeah and so
um that from from that point you know
like the momentum
was was uh started rolling and it was
shifting like my like my mentality and
everything because yo this is this is my
my passion my dream to be an entertainer
yeah and so like as a business owner i'm
i'm i'm not there you know but as an
entertainer i'm like answering these
emails i'm having meetings with these
execs and all these stuff and uh
ironically the most momentum i've gotten
in my career what happened when i moved
from l.a
when i wasn't in l.a you know what i
mean but um but it was also because of
the uh traction and attention that i was
doing because of what the studio was
what it was bringing you know yeah yeah
and so um all of that all of that
happened for a reason you know and so
because of that you know things uh
weren't things where money wasn't coming
in the way it's supposed to my focus
wasn't there and a lot of it got it got
harder like towards the edge but it was
weird though it was it was it was
definitely a um like two sides of it it
was like business isn't going good but
career is going great yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so um it was like uh it
man i got i got i got the letter bro i
got the letter it was like hey
like you owed this much and we need to
buy this day how much was rent by this
time
at the spot oh uh i was paying like uh
uh three g's okay
three yeah and so um and and mind you
like this is i i i didn't have no
investors no no loans this is money out
of my pocket bro i'm paying i'm paying i
there was months where i had like no
business coming in i just paying the
rent you know yes man yeah bro i had no
idea you mean you have you have you guys
have a few restaurants you know oh yeah
they should get rough man
bro yeah man this is this is one of
those things bro we're like i have no
business experience i remember bro i was
talking to you about that right i was
telling you i was like just seeing like
how that stuff runs and you know and and
like no business plan bro i just really
just went off of straight my own
knowledge and experience it was wild bro
i mean it's hard because like when you
open up a business you kind of when you
are the sole proprietor of that business
you are tied to that thing
there is no escape unless you create the
escape so you set up management money
flows really well yeah but that's like a
long time commitment so for most people
who don't open up businesses right like
typically what happens is let's say
you're in the restaurant business yeah
most restaurants fail i think it was
like i forgot what the statistic was it
was like 95 or some [ __ ] that's how much
that's how much restaurants fail
in a span of five years
um within those five years at most
you'll be lucky if you recoup back your
investment yeah and that's if you're
lucky within those five years some
people happen to be very very fortunate
and they recoup it a lot faster
um
but
i think for a lot of us too and i'm
trying to get some of my business
partners you know involved too and this
kind of idea of learning how to create a
business where you don't have to always
be present when you make a business
where you're the sole person there uh
everything is based on you if if you're
not if you're not about it you're not in
it 100 that whole shit's going to fail
yeah
and then finding the right people to
kind of take over is also very hard like
finding good employees or good partners
is very very [ __ ] difficult
absolutely because you'll find out
people don't care about the stuff that
you care about as much as you do right
and then number one it pisses you off
yeah yeah
two it creates bad business yeah right
and three it hinders growth i opened up
that studio in the north side of houston
i'm from i'm from humble you know i was
raised in humble texas
and so it was in that area
now
a lot of people were saying like why did
you open it here you know and not in
houston like downtown or like in the
loop that they would say that this is
like this is where it's popping yeah
it's where it's popping it's also like
the they have studios there too music
studios or art studios and stuff it
would be
but like way smarter to do it there but
i was just so um i was so like uh
i don't even know the word i was just so
stern on the idea of like i want to do
it i wanted my first one to be in my
hometown you know i wish i had a place
like this when i was growing up and i'm
able to do it so like i'm happy that i
made that decision i i have no i have no
regrets bro i just
again bro like whenever whenever it
happened
uh i was kind of just like well this
needed to happen because you know this
is one of the this is one of the the
things that i'm gonna have to sacrifice
and let go because the next part of my
life like this is actually the end of
the
beginning of my life right yeah you know
what i mean so like that's that's how i
that's how i took it bro and like ever
since i've been back in l.a bro it's
been non-stop bro and well you're back
in l.a now in l.a bro and i got here on
a saturday sunday i performed at the
laugh factory and uh uh that was that
was a dope like opportunity because um
i have a i have a really big network
that wanted to come check me out and uh
it rhymes with uh uh fbo okay
so they um they had interest in and
checking me out and they let me know
like yo whenever you whenever you're in
town let us know we'll come check you
out and i kind of like
kind of called her bluff on it you know
i was i i i got a show on sunday i knew
that yeah i was like i got to show i'm
going to be out there these dates i'm
going to perform on this day on sunday
and the thing was is that i hit up uh
the producer shout out to lonnie
lonnie's the one who uh the produced
chocolate sundaes at the lab factory and
i hit her up was like yo like um
i know that it's that it's filled that
your your show's filled up already you
have it's a long line to like you know
she has a rotation she had everything
going i haven't performed there in over
two years
and i was like uh is there any way i can
slide in you know and get a spot and she
was like i'm fully booked but is there a
reason like is there something you need
me to slide you in for she kind of had
that intuition which is cool that was so
dope of her she didn't have to she could
just send on fool and i was like well i
have this network that's coming to check
me out and i've been in in these uh
these meetings and i feel like they they
they want to see me and i want to be on
a dope stage to perform on to show them
and she was like i knew something dope
all right i'll give you i'll give you
eight minutes uh which show do you want
to be on the first or second and i was
like which show do these execs come to
usually and she was like they usually
come to the first show because it's
sunday you know they get in and out
and so that's what i did booked it and
let them know and they never confirmed
with me that they were gonna come but
they showed up bro
i performed and did my thing and then we
went next across the street with my boys
and they were we're just talking about
the show and we're uh you know eating
and stuff like that and i get an email
bro and it's like at 10 30 at night and
i performed at 7 7 30 and so uh they
email and it's from them and they're
like chris
thank you for inviting us you have great
stage presence we love the performance
and uh your wedgie joke had us cracking
up right
but it's cool it's cool when i let look
listen what i lack in language i gain in
moves people
oh i get down
taco tuesday
i get down
that was the one thing that my pops
taught me that's the one thing hey
hey stupid come in here you can't speak
it about it but it's okay you can't take
it for a while
we're in america we're talking listen my
english is perfect listen to me
we pick english
the one thing they're gonna bring
everybody together is what dancing so
i'm gonna teach you right now listen to
me
[Music]
listening to me
and look at what i say
you're going to take in your hand
you're going to take your hand you're
going to give yourself a wage
immediately get yourself away
okay
and you take it out with no hands
hey y'all chris society i appreciate
y'all coming out you have a great night
right and that's how i knew they went
because they ref they were yeah the
reference yeah they referenced a joke
bro so i was like i was like yo they
came and never all the homies were like
yo like you know what i'm saying it was
super cool that they did that they
didn't tell me they didn't even see me
they just saw my performance yeah what
if you bombed exactly that [ __ ] would
have been a disaster i tell you what man
um i was uh i was very confident bro i i
i i that's actually i'm like i'm glad
you brought that up bro cause that's
something that to think about right like
what if i did bomb right but the way
that i've been like uh something
happened to me in houston bro like uh
and they're getting in the right way he
said well i went bro yeah
but they just said golden broke changes
you
when you got nothing to lose
but you literally have nothing to lose
because you have nothing facts bro you
know you don't give a [ __ ] anymore bro
yeah man i mean yeah probably that
probably definitely probably had another
a big influence on it man but like just
being around my family being around my
crew bro like my my boys and my cousins
and like you know i got back dancing bro
like my cousins they they travel the
world break dancing and so i got back in
it and then same thing with my art and
with the studio like and having those
and having those shows i've been i work
my material i'm working my [ __ ] my crowd
work is just boom boom boom right and so
by the by the time i'm here at the laugh
factory i'm already knowing like i'm i'm
good like you got your hours in yeah man
i feel like i got my work in bro and
then even with that like this whole look
bro like my hair i honestly do i i
really let go of like what do i want to
do with my hair bro cause i was like i'm
always i was like insecure about my hair
like fades or what's the the new look or
this and i was just like man i'm just
going to let it rock
full haitian auntie dude
so you know i just let it rock bro and
then even with the shades too bro i made
it i made a choice i was just like man i
like i like who i am i like the feeling
that i'm rocking and you know i i'm i'm
kind of i mean i think that's very
important like i was watching some of
your your standard clips and you look a
lot more confident like you look like
you know your voice now like this is my
stand-up this is what i do and you are
all going to laugh yeah i think that's
the hardest thing to ever acquire in
stand-up is to find your voice i always
was confused about that i'm like my
voice is my voice this is the voice
right now what do you mean yeah and so
like you know when we talk about
observations of like not just stand-up
but anything that you do in life
and just your voice like who you are you
know
obviously stage presence voice is very
different from you know how we apply to
other people who don't do entertainment
right but when you don't when you're not
comfortable in your own skin everything
starts to fall apart because now you're
trying to take a little bit of everybody
else's [ __ ] but you're not really
focusing on what makes you you yeah and
i think that's like the hardest part
about stand-up because when you see a
lot of stand-ups you know like i used to
watch a lot of uh comedy shows like
because it's fun fun to go yeah and i
started noticing like oh there's a
difference in to what makes other people
great and what makes people kind of
funny yeah you're kind of funny because
you got some jokes but i could probably
hear your joke and your delivery from a
million other comments yeah brian i
don't want that yeah and i feel like
what people don't understand too
everybody does about the same jokes yeah
everybody has pretty similar life
experiences it's about how you twist it
how you say it how you present it and
when you don't have your own voice it
just sounds like everybody else's jokes
yeah and i was like damn that's the
biggest difference that's why dave
chappelle is who dave chappelle is right
dave chappelle can command an audience
just by his voice and what he says alone
and nobody does what dave chappelle does
right even somebody like kevin hart
kevin hart has his own style d-ray davis
has his own style yeah uh [ __ ] uh
yeah just name any comic that you have
and you know who they are right i think
that's why like brendan shaw gets like
picked on a lot you know because he's
doing these specials that don't have to
be special when he hasn't found out his
voice yet um you know because i was
looking at his you know i made a lot of
jokes about his special that he really
released recently the gringo poppy and
it was just me you know making jokes
like a lot of comics were doing yeah but
in all honesty like i respect his hustle
i heard about this actually yeah did you
see the stand-up no but i've heard
you're still awake so there's like
there's stuff like
a second i'm kidding
i'm kidding oh yeah i'm kidding but that
was nice great time
great timing
i'm kidding i'm kidding like tim dillon
said something great uh because you know
all these common people they kind of
they [ __ ] with each other right and yeah
they don't want to to rag on another
comment because they would hate for that
to come back to them
but i think for him that you know it's a
big topic you know pikas roasted pretty
hard about a standard special and tim
dillon kind of stated at the best he
goes the problem with the special is
that that material wasn't special worthy
like those are jokes that you could have
kept in a small room worked it and then
made special worthy
content gotcha because there's a
difference like in you know i think what
i started noticing too with certain
comics especially because they had the
whole netflix it's not a joke series if
you guys haven't seen that a lot of big
comics get to bring their friends on and
give them a stage so they could the
world gets to see them work so what i
started noticing is like oh i've seen
these people before the comedy store or
whatever
and they were funny killing it in this
room but they would try to perform their
small room jokes in front of a big crowd
different yeah it's [ __ ] different
yeah and so when i watched netflix as a
joke and billboard was bringing his
friends out uh pete davidson was
bringing his friends out and i'm like i
see these guys
like at the store laugh factory whatever
and they were funny and i see them on
the stage and i'm like oh they haven't
found their voice yet they know their
voice in this small room but when
they're putting it out on stage it
sounds very uncomfortable and it's not
hitting it's just not funny and i'm like
oh that's the biggest difference to why
billboard is who bill burr is even
somebody like pete davidson who's not my
favorite comic
honestly but
his material works on a big stage and i
still think it's funny yeah so that's
like things like finding your voice and
your flow is very [ __ ] important when
i saw your clips i was like oh it looks
like you kind of found your [ __ ] right
like you're not you're not trying to do
these one-off jokes these things kind of
like connect into something bigger which
is very very [ __ ] hard to do it's so
[ __ ] hard you know
yeah bro i've been i've been doing it
like i've been doing that for uh uh
trying to figure out the whole i think i
found my voice in houston bro to be
honest because
um like i said i had i put in the hours
i put in that time and it was in an
intimate space but my studio could only
fit uh uh 50 people you know and um and
it was like and because it's only 50 and
it's such a tight room the every row was
the front row you know they had it so i
was able to like probably just like
work but crowd work bro and like and
like and also come back and make the
make these connect over here this person
connect over here and then you know what
i mean so um i was doing it and then
also even like when i when i have to
work the crowd like if they're it's not
going my way i have to figure out how to
make it so hard dude yeah that's what
gives me anxiety just thinking about it
yeah you know you have to you have to i
just recently that recently happened on
my birthday show at the haha i uh uh uh
i i had to i had to like kind of build
her trust you know what i mean and then
um there was a comic that didn't do so
well like in the mid show i just kind of
[ __ ] up the mood a bit yeah yeah bro
there was there was a there was a there
was a bomb for sure in the middle of the
show and so i i was hosting and so as
the host it's our job to bring them back
up for the next comment because it's not
fair for the next comic you're like it's
not it's not you know their problem and
so um
you know i i knew like i mean some
comics they they'll talk [ __ ] about the
person who bombed but that's not me bro
like i i don't know that's not really my
style and uh i i hate it when it
happened to me when i bomb in the next
the comic the host gets back up and they
[ __ ] make it worse you know they [ __ ]
the dagger's already in there but
they're twisting it yeah yeah yeah i
just left it alone like i didn't even i
honestly didn't even acknowledge it i
just went on stage and went about
another set you know and and got them
back but all that just comes with
experience and then now that i'm like i
am feeling like i found my voice you
know so it's cool to hear that from you
but um i'm just kind of like i'm just
i'm just trusting i trust myself a lot
more you know i just i know like that
confidence it took a while to uh to get
but i didn't realize when i when i moved
back to houston i didn't realize that a
lot of i had a lot of um holes and voids
and stuff that i was like
i was i had in la because in la it's all
about the grind it's all about the
hustle it's all about the network it's
all about you have to kind of do but run
this game that you kind of lose yourself
a little bit and i didn't realize i lost
myself you know yeah and like you you
kind of don't focus on what makes you
special you kind of focus on networking
so much and yeah trying to get people to
give you a leg up versus like creating
your own opportunities yeah and that's
the the really difficult part right yeah
i think like for me personally the
biggest thing that i'm going through is
complacency right because i've done a
lot more than i expected i was going to
do and now it's like okay you have to
refocus and think of a bigger goal like
do you still want to be in entertainment
do you want to do stand-up do you want
to do these things yeah and until like
you're questioning getting back on stage
maybe i mean i've always wanted to go
back but then the hard part for me about
this too it has nothing to do with fear
it has everything to do with like
i know the amount of work it takes to be
a great stand-up and it's such a
struggle and it's so hard and the only
reason why this struggle would make
sense is if i want the end result
if i don't want the end result all this
stuff annoys me because before it never
annoyed me because before it was like i
want to be one of the bigger stand-up
comics out here yeah i want to be that
different asian stand-up besides
everybody else doing ching chong jokes
24 [ __ ] seven so if i do asian jokes
it's going to be different right you
know
she said ching chong
tickled me yeah
it tickled you so
the racism that are in our text messages
[Laughter]
yeah but when i had that like bombing
didn't affect me you know it didn't okay
it affected me but it was like oh that's
just a a piece to the puzzle that i mean
that's the process it's a process but
because i don't have that goal of being
a big stand-up anymore that the the
bombs hurt a little more they don't feel
they don't feel like i'm going to
i care about it a lot more now because
now it's just like oh why am i doing
this you think it's because you also
have a brand to withhold too
i don't know
so you bomb this one it's going to be
one of those like damn david soul just
bombed well i do now
i wasn't thinking that before but thanks
a lot today yeah
well no no i'm sweating no but i mean
that could be that could be it
subconsciously you know i'm saying maybe
you didn't really think i mean i've
definitely bombed a lot so it's like i
know what that experience feels like
right you know like especially just
going up on stage trying your best and
having not not anybody laugh yeah that
[ __ ] hurts yeah yeah yeah no matter how
many years you do for sure yeah just
like oh [ __ ] hey you're not gonna get
off stage going that was [ __ ] great
yeah i go off i'm like yo [ __ ] i'm gonna
kill myself straight up and i feel like
that every [ __ ] time but it didn't
matter because i'm like hey i'm gonna do
better i'm gonna work this joke yeah i
was just like well then so then what
have you uh what has you questioning
going do i hate the stage again i hate a
lot of comics out there i don't think
they're good and i'm like oh i feel like
i'm better right even the even the
because i mean it's not that i'm better
because i am i feel like i can if i work
on it yeah right and you want to buy you
want to back up your [ __ ] talking
exactly so it's like okay what you can
which you know like listen i'm pretty
sure a lot of people when i travel i do
stand up they've heard it it's it's all
right like it's it's okay you know what
i mean so but now it's like
i have to make a set now because i think
one of my bucket list is i do want to do
a special i don't care where the [ __ ] it
goes it'll go on youtube it'll go on
[ __ ] i don't know vimeo as long as i
do it and i get it done yeah and in all
honesty if i wanted to i could probably
write one tomorrow and [ __ ] perform
it next week but who knows it'll be good
i don't know if it'll be good it's funny
in my head but it's always different
when you perform it man you're a funny
[ __ ] bro you know and i've seen
that and i've seen your stand up but you
know i know you and then and and the
conversations we have you're you're
quick bro you're you're you're your
comebacks your rebuttals your stings
they're [ __ ] quick bro you know made
fun of a lot as a kid
you know when you're like that asian kid
in an all-black neighborhood everybody
roasts you so [ __ ] hard every day
yeah i remember just like
one day and i told the story before on
the podcast where i would get mad before
when people would make fun of me yeah
and then what what happens is when you
get mad that's the reaction they want
what you need to do is come back with
them with words words fighting back with
words is 10 times more powerful than you
saying you can beat somebody up right
you look weak so like when you're in a
if you kind of grow up like you know in
a ghetto-ass area everybody just has
jokes right walking to the barbershop
they're [ __ ] clowning on you you
[ __ ] show up with something
mismatched they make fun of you yeah you
don't say anything back you're just the
[ __ ]
the great bro it is exhausting yeah yeah
i watched that show with uh uh uh
patrick cloud with the roast me right
like that oh my god that reminds me of
my childhood so much i get ptsd bro you
should get on there i don't think so
that [ __ ] gives me ptsd because i'm like
that reminds me every time i got a
haircut and i had to [ __ ] prep jokes
so i just want to sit in that chair and
people roast me for an hour straight
getting [ __ ] lined up yeah and i'm
like that gives me ptsd yeah bro hey yo
uh dumbfounder's been on a few episodes
he's out his ground bro well that's why
he's been back he's a he's a battle
rapper oh well yeah but i mean
he got his jokes ready yeah yeah yeah
for sure for sure and tim was on there
too
is that racist that i'm just saying
asian people for you for you
i'm saying you could do it too i could
do it too
the funny thing is too is like we we did
that [ __ ] uh
not roast me but it was the thing that
it kind of bit off roast me that mtv did
it kind of let's just say what it is bro
it did
all right right that was for pat that
was for you pat yeah yeah yeah they kind
of bit off the format i actually didn't
know about pat's show um
and i saw it i was like that is a show
yeah i was like that's his show for sure
either way you can't replicate what he
did to that show because the driving
force of that is patrick cloud
he is the heart and soul of that show
you don't have the heart and soul of
that show how do you expect that show to
do well yeah often imitated and it came
from an authentic place like they they
were roasting in the office just like uh
i remember this is this is kev's story
to share but i mean he he shared it you
know it's uh he he came to work with uh
with a denim uh
vest
and um the the lady at the front some
white chick and she said something but
it but it was in a way of like
the the delivery seemed innocent
but it was a roast bro like is it well i
don't even know the exact thing she said
but it was like one of those like oh is
that what you chose to wear type of
thing and the office went crazy and from
that moment on it opened up the
floodgates of like oh we're gonna roast
and they and the roasting the roasting
started happening and then and then
it was like yo like if you didn't have
anything to roast with bro like you kind
of have to like not go to work because i
would go to that office bro and like
that [ __ ] that's the whole art bro that
[ __ ] is exhausting yeah bro and the
funny thing is like when i was growing
up as a kid like roasting was like my
roast my roast ability now is so much
weaker because i just haven't been doing
it you know like it doesn't really come
as quick as it used to yeah but one of
the things i used to always [ __ ] up on
is i would always take it
too far
yeah yeah that was me yeah that's cause
i can't rose so i would just hurt
feelings exactly someone would be like
you know make an asian joke or something
i was like didn't your dad leave you
yesterday yesterday you [ __ ]
fatherless [ __ ] yeah don't talk
to me
i'm like well i thought we were roasting
yeah bro oh man yeah it's uh it it sucks
it's never good when uh that's that's
kind of been that's been my thing too
that's why i don't roast unless i just
know and i'm confident this is going to
hit which is very rare in the roasting
world but i just stay away from it you
know what i'm saying because i've done
it before and and it hurts feelings bro
and it actually i feel like it makes
relationships a little weird moving
forward and just like damn my best
friend used to say this [ __ ] i roasted
when it came to roasting he was like he
goes your problem is is that you're very
good at finding people's insecurities
and then you just rip into them it's
like hey guys you need to [ __ ] bring
it down a level like uh he has a sister
right and then she she made like one
light joke it wasn't even that big and i
just looked at her i was like stop with
your [ __ ] big ass forehead
you see the her spirit leave her body i
was like ah [ __ ] i did it again then
it's not even really much of a roast
it's just the fact but you could tell
it's like one of their biggest
insecurities or something i called camp
on stage hacky bro
and it hurt them and and my thing was
like
he was roasting me
and and literally bro it was like in
between it was like it was like between
takes on great taste and he's like
sitting in front of me and uh uh it was
like you know it was a roasting
environment you know what i mean and he
threw a roast out or even he was maybe
he was roasting me on camera or some
[ __ ]
i had nothing but i was like i just
recently saw him you know do stand up
and i was like yo kev you know the first
time i saw you do stand up he was like
what's he really saying yeah it's a
little hacky but
like that right yeah it's really soft
very soft very subtle but it was enough
yeah that like that [ __ ] him up bro he
turned around and he was like yo you
don't have to like my comedy
a lot of you know he he and he got like
defensive and i was like
oh we were roasted
i was throwing a rose at you yeah yeah
and
he let me know bro like the next day he
was like yo you really messed me up with
that and i i genuinely apologized to him
i said yo my man like we was i was
roasting bro and i don't even roast like
that you know what i'm saying but i was
cornered and so and i didn't that and i
went for that and i and i know but
what's the worst that you could tell a
comedian bro that they're hacky right
and you know whether whether if whether
it hurts you or if it hurts you even
more that's up to you that you know what
i'm saying like that that's your own
personal thing but like you know that
that like uh he would he would throw
that at me he would it would text me
like like even though he hasn't done it
like recently but like throughout the
years he'd be like remember when you
call me hackie
i'm like bro you still think about that
he's like it haunts me bro i'm like are
you kidding me bro see for me too like
the only thing that would probably
really affect me is like if a comic i
really looked up to called me hacky it
would hurt so bad right for those who
don't really understand what that is
hacky is like uh
easy it's the n word for comics
it's very offensive
you're basically because you're telling
a comic that your your comedy is just
like low fruit it's a trash taco poo poo
jokes yeah you know they're not really
that hard you're just kind of like all
right it's just hacky you know this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my lovely genius brain farts you need to
make sure and understand that you need
to check in on your mental health and
better help is there for you i've been
using it for years and you guys know how
much i love it and i always talk about
mental health because it's important
your thoughts are important things that
you need to get off your chest is
important if you're stressed out from
everyday life try online therapy because
better help is right there for you and
i'm telling you right now it is e z it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can get mesh with the
therapist in under 48 hours you can do
it through video phone and live chat
therapy sessions right at your
fingertips our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's betterhelp.com
genius
but a comedian yo comedians told me that
before like i had i had a joke that was
about um
uh uh back in back when turn up when we
say man we're about to turn up like when
it first came out you know and i and i
and i i thought i made a pretty good
joke it was my first time like first
written jokes where i was like man
everybody's saying turn up turn up turn
up what's gonna be the next thing what's
after turnip you know um and i was gonna
i said that it's gonna go to like death
like tonight we're gonna die tonight bro
y'all down are y'all down to get
together and just kill ourselves yeah
you know and so i went with that but
then uh uh the host one night and he's
seen my set you know uh he's seen that
before a few times and he told me he was
like yo that was kind of hacky and i was
like
what is it is it like i thought it was
pretty good you know and i i worked it i
think because i i yeah i i talked to i
went into like uh you know we're in
we're in the laundry mat and we didn't
have to turn up we turn up anywhere and
it was like bro we're gonna take shots
of bleach bro we were to kill ourselves
i just kind of just went for it but he
was like it was hacky and i was like
damn and and i remembered that like well
one i never said that joke after that
after that i i stopped using it and i'm
glad i did but it was just one of those
things where it's like i mean you take
it and you you figure out what you're
gonna do about it you know what i mean i
mean there's a lot of like
in my personal opinion a lot of comics
who do hacky jokes that are very very
successful though like for some reason
like
i guess like that's my gripe with a lot
of like uh certain asian comics they see
a crowd of white people and they gear
their jokes to make white people laugh
about asian people and i hate that yeah
that [ __ ] [ __ ] pisses me off there's
a few comics like i don't know them
personally right but in my mind's like
you gotta do that yeah yeah why you got
to bring your culture down just to make
these people laugh yeah you know like
your your standup is probably good
without it right you know but then you
have to make these people laugh at stuff
that you know that'll make them laugh
that's what i mean about finding your
voice and i i i have a tendency to do
that when i get nervous i go back to the
stuff that i know will incite a reaction
but it's not the material i want to do
because it's hacky yeah it's hacky to
always just scream and have no point in
it like yeah getting louder stuff is
very important you know when you have
like a certain ebb and flow with your
[ __ ] yeah but it has to go somewhere and
i would have this thing where i would
get nervous when i was younger and i
would just instantly do a quick asian
accent because it wouldn't make them
laugh and i'm like this is pointless
like that asian accent only works if you
set it up right if there's a purpose to
this [ __ ] other than that you're just
using your culture and you're just
[ __ ] it up just to make these people
comfortable because they want to make
fun of you because you're asian right
and then you get nervous and that's what
you give them yeah a lot of asian comics
do that [ __ ] and it bothers me it
[ __ ] irritates the [ __ ] out of me
right right i think that's the [ __ ] that
always makes me nervous it's like
that's all the reason i want to go back
to comedy it's like i could do better
than this like i wanna i don't i don't
know too many asian comics
and they're definitely out there who
have
you know we i talked about this with a
personal friend of mine too he goes yeah
like it's hard for me sometimes to
i just i don't i always default to
talking about asian [ __ ] right which is
fine i don't think it's a problem right
and i think just he's a little critical
on himself yeah because i feel like a
lot of black comics talk about their
blackness a lot right but it's a matter
of if you don't have that what else do
you have to offer yeah
yeah you know like what are your
thoughts right like i'll use dave
chappelle as a great example i always
use dave chappelle because dave
chappelle doesn't position you know
stereotypical black jokes as his go-to
fall fa like fallback right he talks
about his thoughts his perspective and
puts a spin on these things right versus
a lot of other people who kind of use
their culture as a crutch and i don't
want to do that yeah yeah like if i do
do stand-up i gotta make sure that yeah
listen like i said i think actions are
funny and it's our right to do that
because if you're asian you grew up with
that [ __ ] use it in your [ __ ]
stand-up yeah just how you go about it
is different right hey i use mine but
and i and i use mine because i i can't
speak spanish yeah so the best thing
that i have is a talk like this i could
do the accent all the time and i and i
can convince people that maybe maybe
english is my second english yeah but i
but i do that and
and that's why it's like okay
and i i it's it's the thing where it's
like um you know man white people do
this man us like you know people we
don't do that latinos we do this and
it's kind of like ah but see like the
funny part of the joke isn't the accent
though it's the it's the inside jokes
about the culture that's fun right
that's why it's funny it's not because
you know i went up on stage and i was
like hello everybody
[Laughter]
which by the way hilarious
like if i just walked up on stage and i
was like
yeah i was like nehou
how are you you know no no no i like
head whoa better wow
hey let me tell you this funny ass
[ __ ] story you know bart right yeah
so during this time
we had this company called go for broke
what we did with that company we donated
to the gopher broke foundation all of
our proceeds are closed whatever we gave
it all to them
uh so before we do all that stuff uh we
decided they wanted us to give a speech
and it was to this uh chinese-american
after-school thing right
and there was people who didn't speak
english they spoke mandarin bart speaks
mandarin and i'm like oh this is a great
way for us to connect to our asian
community let me tell you what this
[ __ ] bart is bart walks up on
stage right he grabs the mic first word
he says that comes out of his mouth
hello
[Laughter]
i was like
you just see mark saying bart's cracking
up to himself ain't nobody laughing no
way i'm mortified i'm like no they
didn't they didn't
do they know bart
no
oh because this is this is a formal
event yeah like the mayor of like
monterey park is there bro and there's
like these old chinese people he just
goes hello i'm like son of a [ __ ] this
[ __ ] dude
yo man i love bart bro that fool's nuts
i love him bro like
man you gotta understand bro like this
is like beginning youtube days where i'm
watching
tim delaghetto when he's tim dalai
ghetto now he's uh chantarongsu but uh
of his his name but uh bart and joe
just kidding phil
those were my three cats yo i was
watching and nigahiga yeah yeah yeah oh
asian cats yeah that i was watching yo
and uh i knew you when you were fat you
know what i'm saying and now you know
thanks very much
you were hacky and fat like oh well
that's even more unnecessary
you're a businessman
hey bro hey bro
hey hey yo i asked uh i asked my boys i
asked my quick little sidebar i asked my
boys because i'm i'm writing something
right now because i'm having meetings
with execs [ __ ] yeah
i've had those i've already done what
you've done
yes sir you have a film of sundance no
all right cool
[Laughter]
shall we continue
you're on my podcast right that's crazy
oh [ __ ]
no i have no friends
this is why i have no [ __ ] friends
today bro
look at my eyes
oh you can't tell
i'm sorry
i'm sorry to the asian community that i
was cornered
you see what i mean
oh [ __ ]
okay so look so uh i asked my homies bro
i was like yo i'm writing something
right now um but i'm trying to roast
myself in in the uh in the script and
i'm just i'm just so perfect i can't
find the words you know but i was like
telling my boys like yo y'all just roast
me just give me dope no mercy whatever
and my boys you know they threw rose so
at that and i was kind of like man y'all
could go harder bro like you know i was
doing i'll do some basic [ __ ] my weak
ass beard and you know saying you know
they were going my hair and [ __ ] like
that and i was like nah y'all can go
harder and my boy goes
i'm gonna [ __ ] you bro your business was
wack and it never worked they started
going about my studio and i was like
hold on a second i said i was like okay
y'all are warming up
i was like hey so we're done we're not
friends anymore
you know your business didn't work bro
you lying somehow your momentum
your business didn't work bro
you tried and it failed
yo when the homies roast you like that
that [ __ ] is so painful it's like hey
well you gotta go there
but you know what bro that's how i know
that that's how i know they love me you
don't say it's this form of a dear man
he said that right now because you care
that reminds me of this roast that i did
recently
you know like when uh you roast a friend
on like a story yeah and it just says
red but they reply back i'm like ah [ __ ]
i [ __ ] up
you had to send a lmao after like like
to show them it was a joke that we're
laughing right like lol exclamation
just kidding how you been
you good
hey miss you bro yes
you know checking in on your mental
health like how you been [ __ ] leaving
voicemails and [ __ ] because this will
always be posting yo back on my fitness
grind back on my fitness grind and i'm
like
dog you are the only person i know that
has posted this for [ __ ] 12 years
straight and you've gotten fatter and
like i just wrote that to him real quick
on that dj khaled yeah and i wrote that
to him real quick he just left it all
red people has responded back to me hey
[ __ ]
you know me like we've been friends for
like 10 years it's like come on man you
know what you were doing with your
[ __ ] constant fat stories how are you
[ __ ] worse than your before pick like
that doesn't make any sense yeah yeah
yeah that's not that's not cool bro yeah
but you know cause he's trying to lose
weight because he has a wedding coming
up next year
and he's like yo i'm back on that
fitness grind i was like just buy a
bigger suit
that'll do it bro my problem is like
after that one joke i made like two or
three more after yeah every slide yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
oh wow you're really good with it i
guess that was like a little personal
thing i didn't know that he felt a
certain way you kind of just have to
know you have to know who you're dealing
with right like if you're if you you
throw anything at me that is an insult i
know it's coming from a great place yeah
you're roasting me you know what are you
gonna say like if somebody doesn't know
me and they're throwing it at me then
it's kind of just like whoa yeah i would
never say to somebody that's not a good
friend yeah if it's like even like an
acquaintance they don't get i don't talk
to them like that that's what i'm saying
it's like yo like you can't be you can't
be that offended bro come on bro look
like you know i mean man like my cousin
bro i like i i was uh
i i said something but like we're like
playing we're playing pool right and uh
where it was like on teams and so uh it
was his turn and he he missed whatever
and i was just like oh he missed just
like his sex life right and bro my man
didn't talk to me the entire day bro and
i was like he literally was ignoring me
like i was right next to him and he just
wasn't saying a word i'm like oh that's
a pretty soft one you good bro soft that
was really soft yeah yeah and and out
and i was kind of like what the [ __ ] is
going on i had i didn't know that that
was the reason at the time i just know
i'm like yo my man's ignoring me and
then we're kind of like with a group and
it's noticeable everybody's kind of like
yo you're good and uh he called me the
next day and was like telling me like
hey bro this is what it is this is what
it was instead and he's like you know
it's kind of like he's kind of going
through that right now it's just
insecurities and i'm kind of just like i
was like damn so the joke was that good
i was yeah
i wasn't the joke was that good yeah but
but i'm kind of just like bro like we're
cousins but we're fam like you know and
even the way i'm like yo like i wouldn't
if i would have known that that would
have made you act like that i would have
never said 100 you know what i'm saying
like you know also to keep your
composure and then talk about it after
yeah you know but uh but you know it's
it's it's that that's one of my things
though it's like it's like know who
you're talking to you know say it like i
remember in high school i still remember
this rose because it got me so bad
because i can't grow sideburns and then
they saw the side of my hair he was like
david got japanese [ __ ] here on the
side of his head
and dog
i [ __ ] cried laughing because of how
[ __ ] funny that [ __ ] was dude this
[ __ ] said i had to walk around
with my cybers pixelated and that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] till this day makes me laugh
oh my god i remember just everybody died
laughing slowly and i was trying to
roast him back but i couldn't stop
laughing at his jokes
but i couldn't stop laughing i was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny dude
and i've used that roast on somebody
else too credits to him by the way when
i roasted somebody back with that [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] hilarious yeah
i think what made it so funny too is
that he never rose people but for some
reason that day he was on one just had
it and he got me so [ __ ] hard
and i it's like i love that [ __ ] when
your friend roasts you to the point
where i'm i'm laughing as hard as
everybody else is i can't say [ __ ]
yeah bro i think i think uh that's the
i just read a text writer this is my
friend but like he he goes i text him a
screenshot of the movie ticker i'm gonna
go watch thor right and i and he say
text back he goes i don't care and i and
i'm going with him
he goes i don't care and i was like i go
i go you love me right and i said you
always love me you always care and you
love me and he just told me right now he
says i love the idea of you not actually
you that's [ __ ] hilarious that's just
how like i don't know bro i mean if you
if you ever go into like this is why i
always say too when people
kind of uh try to cancel people off of
like text messages that they see from
other people yeah i can't believe you
said that i was like show me your text
messages
like i want to see your text message
that you would you text your friends and
your boys all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you
guys sent because a lot of times when
people joke around like that we're
allowed to go to the far end of darkness
and comedy with our friends yeah because
we know it's between us we would never
repeat it to somebody else that's not
how we feel it's just stupid it's dumb
and you see that a lot but all those
same people they'll type like i can't
believe you would say something even in
your private conversations show me your
text yeah straight up i want i want to
see it man let me see them group chats
oh the group chats are [ __ ] wild dude
you know bro all my boys are like
working entertainers like bro my boy my
boy is jake from state farm that's like
one of the homies oh [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying i get that [ __ ]
canceled tonight
but you know saying like bro like the
group chats bro the group chats are
insane bro you're kind of just like oh
my god that's why i always go in on the
on the celebrities who go online and
they trash other people about like being
holy and pious right like oh like i'm
this shining light of what's moral and
[ __ ] yeah and those are the people i
always go in on the most is because like
bro i know you and i know your circle
and i know how much of a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] you are yeah it's like at any
[ __ ] moment i become a [ __ ]
millionaire everybody i'm canceling
watch you just wait all you
[ __ ] out there that have been
so hard trying to cancel other people
for [ __ ] that you've been doing all your
shit's leaking yeah that's worse yo
that's the worst i hate that [ __ ]
because like you guys are all in
entertainment yeah you know these
private conversations are sometimes
weird and [ __ ] up yeah but it's
because we're throwing dumb jokes at
each other yeah right and we're saying
in the comfort of our boys
yeah for sure girls too girls do the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] 100 like listen i've i
could
i just got a glimpse of one of my
homegirls like group chats that they
have you want to talk about men who
objectify women dog this female group
chat is wild dude
sending them dig pics to each other's
[ __ ]
yo that's what's wild it's like they're
sending the dick pics that they've
received and they send it to the girls
it's one of those like what did they say
yeah
though it's like damn they it's the same
it's the same thing bro i really i've
really let go of the idea of like men
and women are different they're not they
really stay like sexually or the way
that [ __ ] like we're human beings you
know we think that we think about these
things we say these things we we do
these actions it's like yo do men cheat
more than women i don't know because you
know what i'm saying that's like even
for me when people ask
people have asked me to talk about this
for a lot it's like yo talk about that
reddit thread with like you know where
people talk [ __ ] about you and like jk
all your friends i'm like why why do i
have to do that it's not because i'm
better than them it's just those people
are just like me yeah like we're just
talking [ __ ] yeah so why do i have to go
out of my way and stop people talking
[ __ ] about me on reddit when i do the
same thing you do bro yeah you know i'm
gonna be the first person to say you do
be talking i've been talking [ __ ] it's
like i'm not any better than those
people on reddit the only difference is
i show my face and i'm not afraid to
stay in front of somebody's face
behind whatever whatever i say behind
your back i'll say it directly to your
face ten times more yeah so
really what they're doing is relatively
harmless right they found entertainment
you know hating on people that's fine i
don't i don't care because
if i say you should shut down that
reddit page then i'm being a hypocrite
because at the end of the day
they are just discussing about [ __ ]
about me that they hate that i put out
into the ether yeah so whatever they saw
how they interpret it is how it's what's
allowed right right it's how they
interpret it yeah they don't like the
[ __ ] that i say oh i won't be talking
about me cheating on my ex anymore
that's for sure had learned that on this
podcast too what is it three podcasts to
go let me tell you something hilarious
that [ __ ] was great dawg
was like
it didn't make it any better when like
people looked me up and that like at the
time your your podcast was like the the
first thing that was popping up when you
look up my name and it was that title oh
[ __ ] yeah i'm over here like i almost
wanted to be a [ __ ] right and just like
hit you up like yo can we like reword
the title like i could have you know i
know you could have you beat the [ __ ]
yeah but but either way regardless it's
like
like you piece of [ __ ]
what do you think
well uh but i mean regardless i'm in
control of my narrative nobody could you
know i mean like what are you gonna say
like you found out you caught me no like
i i'd say well i don't understand why
people made such a big deal about it
because
i
cheating is pretty common
you know what i mean and a lot of people
too
that's the thing i don't like man like i
don't know how many times i could tell
you how many people that i know that
have cheated i'm going on three years
being single by the way that's just the
longest that i've never been i've ever
been single bro i haven't been single
for this long i've always been in a
relationship is that by choice
uh being single yeah for sure bro and i
and i and it was because of uh
again when i moved to houston but not
even i would say before that too when i
when i uh uh like got out of that
relationship um the i realized i was
kind of just like thinking back of like
the seven years that i was living in in
la seven five out of those seven years i
was in a relationship with you know i
mean it was different relationships but
i just added them up and it was bro five
out of the seven i moved out here to
chase a dream to be an entertainer yeah
i invested five years of my time bro and
for another person you know i mean i'm
not regretting it but i also have to
understand i'm like damn what did that
what would that feel like if i if i was
five years before just me and so that's
kind of like my thing of like what you
say what that sounds like you're running
it a little bit no no i don't because i
learned a lot i learned a lot from every
single relationship i know not to live
with a chick not to cheat not to cheat
for sure you know
uh you know me i would not go public
with the relationship like go you know
what i mean like i've i've tried it i've
done it with uh two relationships and
i'm kind of just like i'm cool on that
you gotta find my thing is like when you
uh
you know go public with the relationship
right it really matters who the person
is that you go public with right okay so
my girl is not a social media person um
right right
she literally does it and posts whenever
she feels like it if it's fun right
doesn't care about likes doesn't care
about follows doesn't care about any of
that [ __ ] yeah and she's just
enjoying it having fun right if you have
somebody that's trying to leech off of
your success or wants to be a part of
all your [ __ ] yeah that's where it
becomes problematic because now this is
a business with us i want to make this a
business you know that's where it gets
really funky where like
uh the concern goes how come you don't
post me it's like why are you why are
you asking that yeah
because what's gonna happen if i don't
oh do you want some followers do you
want followers or do you wanna
so some girls they just wanna they wanna
let other girls know that you're taken
you know what i'm saying or it's it's
they they also want the to be like yo
i'm the one who who he's with you know i
mean it's there's a lot of there's a lot
i understand why they would want to be
seen but for me i'm like
i already i already say so much about my
personal life i want to have some piece
of privacy oh uh you know
and there was a big reason why for me
for the longest time i didn't put muriel
on this podcast
and we have a certain way of joking like
we [ __ ] with each other a lot like we
roast each other we argue we bicker back
and forth all of our all of our friends
know this about us that's how we used to
flirt that's how we worked since the day
we got together nice people see that
they look at this toxic relationship i'm
like
this is how we [ __ ] with each other yeah
like it's how we [ __ ] yeah
we don't ever [ __ ] but we [ __ ] with each
other a lot
you know like we we literally do that
all the time
and there was this podcast episode where
you know i was telling her like before
she come on the podcast this is a comedy
podcast so let's just joke around and
then we we would like do these like
little these stupid arguments where
we're bickering and this is not these
aren't big deals but we're just trying
to be entertaining and funny and people
are like look at this toxic relationship
look how david doesn't let her do things
how he talks over her i'm like
okay so this bit's not working
you know
and then you know so i stopped bringing
her on yeah because
what was being perceived versus how we
actually are and they're like well this
is how it is and they would project
their personal relationships on ours
it's like
this is not and it's not worth
explaining yeah i was like this is a
podcast yeah you're not there with us in
our personal lives there's 99 of stuff
about maryland people will never ever
know because she's you know i'm with her
right we have very personal things
you'll never know that stuff you'll
never know how we are behind closed
doors you'll never know like our certain
level of affection all that other [ __ ]
is going to be a mystery to you for the
rest of your [ __ ] lives yeah because
it's none of your [ __ ] business yeah
and i like it that way it makes it more
special right right yeah for sure like
if i tell personal stories about like
girls it's never about sexual stuff or
crazy personal [ __ ] about mario it's all
my previous past relationships
because i i'm protecting not only her
image but who she is as a person right
you'll never know you don't know any of
the [ __ ] that goes on with me and her
when i tell all these like weird stories
about women it's never about her it's
always about somebody from the past yeah
yeah bro yeah i'm i'm just uh i'm just
i've really been big on like protecting
uh uh i don't know this it's gonna sound
cliche it's kind of the thing with snap
was like protecting my energy protecting
you know i mean like oh you definitely
moved back to l.a yeah i'm saying yeah
bro i've been i mean but i was i was
learning that back home man i was
learning from my cousin shout out to be
easy uh really being about like you know
like you don't really realize like how
much energy you're putting into somebody
else i mean literally when you're having
sex like when you when you you when you
exchange that like we are we're we're i
mean i can speak for myself but i could
you know you as well we're we're very
like uh we're legendary people bro i
mean i put that clip about put that clip
about the other podcast we had over here
but like we really are like some great
human beings bro and like to just me as
a single person to just go out and just
like have sex with a shorty it's like
they get all of that energy of like who
i am and all this
what i've all this work and who i've
become and they just get that you know
and what do i get in return you know
you've got to find somebody that kind of
really helps build you yeah right and
that's the hard part of finding that
that really good partner and i think
that's like what kev has you know kev
has mrs kev on stage yeah they seem to
build i mean i don't know them
personally like that but they seem to
build each other up yeah they build
their businesses up squad is dope yeah
he's a she's a part of his business
beyond stages yeah they're the on stages
yeah it's really [ __ ] nice to see
that [ __ ] yeah hell yeah and i think
like that's what people should want not
so much like his his wealth and his
success but just having a partner there
that's there for you and i straight up
yeah it's just nice man man that
companionship man it's it's it's real
i've seen it live i've been on i've been
uh fortunate kev was uh you know brought
me on the road with him a few uh dates
and stuff and i've seen that seen it
live you know what i mean and and how
they are as a family how they are as a
business partners and how they are
working like yo it's it's uh it's
definitely inspiring to see bro they're
a [ __ ] unit dude yeah it's cool it's
super cool if you didn't cheat you would
have that too all right you know kev
tried throwing that at me and i was like
you cheat on diet
you cheat on diet and then he texted you
a month later hey man i'm still thinking
about it yeah yeah yeah bro he tried
that like he tried using that on me it
was just like but you cheated on her and
i was like but you cheat on diet bro so
we're i don't know i think i'll tell you
this right now man it's like i was like
i gotta just lose this extra 20 pounds i
gotta take the fat jokes away from
people on the roast once that's gone you
got nothing [ __ ] yeah it was
like asian jokes so i gotta work have a
workaround around that you know i have a
i have a phrase shout out to rose a a
virtual rose virtual reality uh [ __ ] in
houston and she was helping out the
studio she was she was the reason i had
like 360 comedy shows and she's a big
fan of you bro oh really yeah she says
she misses uh fat david oh dog everybody
says that [ __ ] it's too cute now what's
up [ __ ]
but but no she is a big fan of you bro i
i'm glad it's popped in my head bro you
know what the funny thing is is like i
had to
to to really think about the whole fat
thing and the funny thing right because
i kind of tied my identity to being a
big guy so much that it was it was
detrimental to me you got the jonah hill
effect yeah it really was that [ __ ]
right it's like oh fat is synonymous
with david and i always assumed
with myself it's like
oh if you're not fat you're not going to
be funny and a lot of my standup was a
lot of fat jokes about myself and you
know what there was a big trigger moment
where i was out in the south and i was
doing a set and i made you know
self-deprecating fat jokes about myself
but in the south i'm skinny these
[ __ ] are fat and they didn't
get the jokes i was like oh
it's like i've used this [ __ ] so much as
a crutch i just stopped being funny yeah
i just started using this just like i
was using these cheap asian hacky asian
jokes yeah now i'm using these hacky fat
jokes
right and there's ways to do fat jokes
where it's not hacky but i used it as a
crutch and i'm like okay these there's
like pieces to this puzzle to why i
should lose [ __ ] weight obviously the
health thing and all this other stuff
was another reason too yeah but those
were these like little clicking moments
where i'm like oh this isn't a really
good thing to have yeah you know when
people are like oh i miss fat david's
like well you miss fat david because you
relate to that person because you're fat
oh [ __ ] you know
so you see
greatness in me and you want to feel
okay with yourself because i'm fat so as
long as somebody you look up to is fat
you're okay with it but if i lose weight
you lose this here same thing that's the
[ __ ] that happened with lizzo
all the people who like you
who like fat or they're fat my fans are
only fat
[Laughter]
with a ph with a ph
no that's but that's really what i
realized i got a lot of messages like
that they're like oh you're like our fat
king and i was like weird [ __ ] you know
like you were a [ __ ] blubber baby
but they were just they would see my
buddha
you're my big baby buddha i'm like cool
all right let's [ __ ]
they they saw something in me that they
saw in themselves and they wanted to be
like oh this big guy has confidence i
could have confidence too
and you know when i lost the weight they
kind of lost like this
they didn't feel comfortable being big
because i wasn't big anymore and i'm
like well that's a deeper problem that
you have right that's something that you
have to figure out yeah
and a great example of this too or maybe
maybe just even representing
insecurities so maybe even if they
weren't fat their rep you were
representing being confident in your
skin yeah right being confident in what
would be an insecurity as being fat yeah
and that's a really good point too you
know i was telling this one kid so i
just tried saving all your supporters
bro you caught all your supporters fat
bro well fat is not a bad thing fat
chamber there you go
cancel them so
[Laughter]
uh this is like for the select amount of
big people that were dming me right and
there was a guy that i saw recently i
went on a hike and he was a bigger dude
he's a fan of mine and i looked at him
and i already knew his prototype because
his prototype was my type everything it
was like 100 degrees and this was
wearing all black i'm like i know why
you wearing all black because you're
self-conscious about
you know the way you look yeah you know
when you wear dark clothes it hides your
fatness or whatever right
i see that and then i go hike into this
waterfall and i take off my shirt and
i'm going in there and i come back out
and loki what he said it was a little
offensive but he was like bro you got a
lot of confidence i'm like
[ __ ]
you're brave yeah you're you're brave
you're you're you're a national hero why
because you took your shirt off hey [ __ ]
you go die but he was a fan
and i was like yeah man
go in the waterfall and he goes nah man
i can't do all that i was like why it's
like a big guy man i want to take off my
shirt in public i was like what's the
problem now you're just keeping your
shirt on just because you're going to
make other people feel uncomfortable
because you're ashamed ashamed of what
if you're fat you're fat yeah you know
it ain't hiding it yeah i was like that
waterfall feels [ __ ] good and you
want to go in there just [ __ ] go in
there yeah like what are you tripping
about yeah like you're not gonna have
this experience in your life that you
really [ __ ] want because you're
overweight yeah you know this about
yourself right everybody who sees you
knows you're overweight whether you keep
that shirt on or not is this shirt
they're gonna go whoa this guy's been
fat though
they're like holy [ __ ] yo yeah i was
like bro if anything else if you go in
that waterfall with your shirt on doug
that's a wet t-shirt contest what are
you talking about it might be better if
you just take off your [ __ ] shirt
yeah yeah and so i was talking to him
guy takes off his shirt i
goes into that waterfall yeah how does
that feel
i was like hey it feels [ __ ] good man
i still feel like people are watching me
i was like let them [ __ ] watch you
then whatever who the [ __ ] cares yeah
like now you're in that waterfall and
now you feel [ __ ] good yeah now just
take that [ __ ] and run with it like
anytime you go to a pool you go to a
[ __ ] lake you're at a beach you take
off your [ __ ] shirt and go in that
water it doesn't matter what people
[ __ ] think yeah it's just it's a
weird thing and it's like that mental
thing that people have from david soda
david goggins real quick bro stop being
a [ __ ] yeah stay hard stay hard dig
hard body hard
yeah but like watching him it reminded
me of myself a lot yeah right where he's
so concerned about this thing and i
asked him too i was like why are you on
this hike he goes because i want to lose
weight
that's great you want to lose weight the
process is just as important as
important as the end goal right it's
like i never lost weight because i hated
myself process is just as important as
the end goal yeah like that it's all
about that [ __ ] i was like
you not appreciating yourself is not
gonna change just because you lose the
[ __ ] weight yeah that's something
that you have to deal with before you
lose the weight because if you don't
deal with that [ __ ] you'll gain that
weight right the [ __ ] back yeah cause
what if you get a breakup what if you
lose your job mm-hmm
what are you going to go back to you're
going to go back to that [ __ ] same
guy that kept his shirt on at that
[ __ ] waterfall because you were
afraid that people were going to judge
you right you didn't fix that [ __ ] yeah
so when you go do things in life just do
it you know it's so weird because i'm
lecturing this fool in the middle of a
hike that i just met where but you know
i'm basically talking to him like i'm
talking to myself seven eight years ago
yeah you know but it felt good to watch
that kid take off his [ __ ] shirt and
go in that [ __ ] wall that's tight bro
you know
yeah i hope you know i don't know if
he's watching this but he says he
listens to the podcast and i'm really
glad he did and i hope he's still losing
weight and killing it you know hell yeah
bro good [ __ ] yo that's tight that's
tight did y'all split a slim jim after
that
i sucked his dick actually
[ __ ] stay hard
stay
this is your gift me lord
hello
hello
oh [ __ ] why don't you see your thing
that's good bro [ __ ] man
yeah bro's [ __ ] life right yeah this
is how how we're getting down man so
when you walk outside with that [ __ ]
up hair of yours don't even [ __ ]
worry what bro i've been getting the
most compliments i've ever gotten in my
hair bro like this bro it's pretty cool
yeah they appreciate the trans movement
that you're a part of and they [ __ ]
love it let me tell you something bro
i'm in transition right now bro it's a
process you know what i'm saying it's
definitely i'm glad you moved back
though this is where you should be yeah
bro it feels that it feels that way it
feels it feels like uh i i i should be
here and i'm glad i'm glad it does i'm
glad that it doesn't feel uncomfortable
like was this the right move and it's
like i got i got a dope support system
bro like when you found out i was here
you hit me like right away bro like you
know what i'm saying and you've been
trying to kick it with me and i haven't
i've been flaky because i haven't had a
car out here my uber's the ubers are
[ __ ] crazy bro you live way too far i
completely understood when you told me
you didn't have a car i was like hey
just stay at home yeah these ubers are
pricey oh it's insane i've been driving
my car to the airport and just parking
it there because it's cheaper than the
[ __ ] uber dude it's crazy bro and you
know they have this feature now with
like if you can't uh pay the uber the
uber because i'm such a reliable uh uh
customer it's on them right and i was
like oh
damn that's cool right oh really and
then and then i ran it again and it said
can't your the payment didn't go through
but since you're such a reliable
customer it's on us and i'm like where
is this going yeah because i'm gonna
keep doing this until it stops yeah bro
and then eventually they they uh where
they hit me with the doke they said um
you have some uh rides that you haven't
completed and it sends me to the list of
the ones that they were on them yeah
basically saying like we got it right
now but you got it obviously right it's
like they got to pay later so like yeah
i went through all that whole little
system my first like couple weeks out
here that's what's so crazy about that
bro and i and and i don't want to like i
mean i don't know it's been a little
minute but i
i want to share this man
like
people people uh it's all a lot of it's
perception right and we say this on uh
like uh on instagram where they say like
a lot of people are fake flexion or a
lot of people everybody it's all fake i
know yeah you know and you know what
they're probably there are people who
are fake flexion right and then there's
people who um they they only post when
there's positive stuff what is happening
so when it when or their accomplishments
and all these things and and not
necessarily happy at home and and that's
another story too
and like what for me bro my example is
that like
i performed at the lab factory
nobody knows that i'm i was negative 800
yeah i'm negative bro but i'm on stage
and i'm and i got my voice i got this
confidence i'm walking as if i have a
million dollars in my account my account
doesn't represent me you understand and
so like i'm posting all these things and
i have this feeling of like you know i i
feel like i treat my instagram what i
think a lot of people do they treat it
like it's it's your house you hang up
nice art pieces you don't hang up your
[ __ ] negative account you're a
diction letter you don't hang up those
you hang up the things that you're most
proud of or your family photos and all
these things that's how i consider it
and so you know i don't really stress
too much about what other people are
trying to perceive like they want us to
be like you know uh you know is it fake
or is it not bro like bro like
my my uh
i want i want to say this to inspire
those who are maybe they're struggling
financially all these things it's like
the money is always going to come always
going to come just as long as you just
keep moving forward and you keep that
forward motion you don't just sit around
just like moping and kind of like
feeling depressed and all these things
like yo give yourself an hour to feel
that and then and then get up you know
and do something you know what i mean
because you know i got i got an editing
gig you know what i'm saying i got this
i got this and then like money started
rolling in and okay cool i'm back but yo
like for a minute bro had no money
that's because i i kind of told on
myself with the whole uber thing when i
said the car declined yeah yeah my my
cars were declining bro and i'm still
out here you know what i mean because it
was like
you know if if you're not if you're new
to this or a lot of people didn't make
the move to go to la because they know
it's expensive especially right now the
way gas prices are and all this stuff
bro it's like oh my god i don't even
feel like a forerunner like an idiot bro
and you know and and the thing is it's
like
it's literally you're you're you can
make whatever you want to make of it you
know what i'm saying like if you if you
if you want to make it out here you can
you can absolutely make it out here
legally you don't say like you don't
have to do no wild [ __ ] you could just
you just have to be efficient you just
have to keep going you're going to be
negative you know what i mean like i've
been negative so many times i got
evicted twice the seven years i lived
out here i've got evicted you know i've
been back on the couch you know what i'm
saying i'm staying on my cousin's couch
right now you know what i mean but i'm
not that doesn't it doesn't scare me it
doesn't make me a less of a man it
doesn't make me feel like oh you so
you're just out here faking on the
ground no i'm not i'm doing what i'd
love to do this is like it doesn't make
me a loser it doesn't mean it doesn't
make me a loser it doesn't make me it
doesn't make me a [ __ ] failure he
doesn't make me it does not
you know just because i lost my studio
yeah you know uber's pitting me yeah
yeah bro but i mean i'm just saying that
man because like you know uh it doesn't
don't let it stop who you are yo you
know what i mean like have you had still
rock the the confidence that you have
and still be the person who you are and
you know do like honestly man i do what
it makes me happy and the money comes
yeah you know
uh um issa didn't have to hit me up you
know she didn't have to all i was doing
was doing what like i was staying in my
lane and i was in houston i didn't want
to sit around doing nothing just gaining
weight and being with my fam i wanted to
create something i wanted to be on stage
i wanted to keep that same urgency that
i've always had in la that same drive
and i just made a path yo you know and
people saw people were noticing issa
looked out so it's like all i did was do
what i love to do and make people laugh
and that's still what i'm doing the
usher thing the us the dominican usher
went [ __ ] viral bro and usher
retweeted it you know what i'm saying
yeah
it's like okay cool but does that make
me rich
nah but like cool i'm all i'm doing is
just just building this this momentum
yeah and i'm telling you man like people
definitely like to flex a lot because
they feel like that's the thing to do
yeah uh
and i've been to a lot of these events
where i've seen these people who are
influencers and some of them are doing
really really well and some of them are
faking it you know you know they show me
their [ __ ] i'm like oh that's really
cool like all right like what does this
mean to me you know like oh yeah you
know we should do works or video
together it's like i'm not here for
anything i'm here to watch a [ __ ]
movie where you guys do your own thing
yeah
you know i see some of these guys and
some of these young kids are super
[ __ ] cool but i have met a handful of
them
who definitely flex really hard like
they're living it up but then i see them
at the event i see what they roll up in
it's like
oh only one of you have a car and
there's six of you riding in this [ __ ]
and you guys live in an apartment and
you're broke you guys flex like you have
a lot of money though yeah you know your
insurance help buy a lot of stupid [ __ ]
when you're broke as [ __ ] no what the
[ __ ] are you doing right like all that
money will come it's like no it might it
might but you're on a platform like tick
tock that doesn't make money yeah so
what you're doing yeah you know yeah but
they make these kids believe that
they're living the best life and i
literally see them [ __ ] split a
grilled cheese sandwich it's like bro
you are broke and that's okay yeah
yeah that's the thing it's okay to be
broke and it's also like if it makes for
even better content you know what i'm
saying talk about that you know i mean
make that that that content you know i
made the best content when i was just
down and out yeah because i had this
chip on my shoulder like yeah you know
me and tim talk about this a lot it's
like dude when we were broke we would
have done anything we could to stay as
creative as possible yeah a lot of the
times our issue is complacency like we
lost our drive and our hunger yeah
drive because your tesla's doing all the
driving
hey i got a full runner now like a
[ __ ] idiot
right i was like oh i'm done with this
tesla i'm gonna get this forerunner yeah
it turns out gas costs like 700 a month
i should have kept the tesla i'm a
[ __ ] idiot yeah but now i'm just like
now even for me
i had that phase two when i was making
uh you know a lot of money
and i wasn't reinvesting it at all i was
just buying whatever the [ __ ] i wanted
got the tesla got the kicks got
everything yeah and then i was just like
this shit's useless
like i i do understand why like and like
different strokes for different folks
right and when i say people who are
materialistic i'm not saying that as a
knock i'm saying if that's you that's
you like buying nice dope [ __ ] makes you
happy then hey that's you yeah but that
wasn't it for me and i thought it was
yeah and i once i got rid of that [ __ ]
i'm like okay let me refocus on the
things that i love like you know
developing this brand secret society
like it's contemporary fashion basics
i'm trying to create something in a
space where it doesn't exist
right high fashion basics that isn't
going to cost you [ __ ] 300 for a
hoodie it'll be
their quality and even better at a
fraction of the price yeah and that's
what we're trying to do it's not it's
not fast fashion it's not going to be 30
40 hoodies right for sure and when
people receive the products they
understand that right but i've been
trying that because it's a passion doing
the matcha [ __ ] is a [ __ ] passion
yeah doesn't have anything to do with
entertainment any of that stuff but it's
something that i want to complete
because it's what i want yeah right yeah
and i think that was hard for me too
because i was like oh i'm supposed to be
a comic i'm supposed to be an
entertainer what am i doing this matchup
business for right but i rerouted my
thoughts and i was like no this is what
i want
if i want it i should take it yeah and
now i'm letting other people [ __ ] yap
in my ear about what i should do it's
like no no no i'm gonna do what i want
to do
right and then pursue it 100 and see
what happens with it yeah and if it
becomes creative space houston that's
what happens yeah
and then i hope you have another space
on your couch for me
we gonna split the cushions in half
bro man listen bro listen my thing is
like i just it's on pause you know
that's how i put it that's on pause man
until you know i handle business out
here and and then i go back out there
and go bigger and better you know what i
mean maybe get in the place where
there's not homeless people jacking each
other off well that too and uh yeah yeah
cause uh because yeah there's a lot
going on bro there's a lot going on the
hotel next door to me i was like
but the good thing is is like you get to
refocus but i really do feel it was a
good thing just from watching your new
stand-up it's different it's all
different yeah the vibes are different
the delivery is different everything is
[ __ ] different like you look like a
different person on stage i was like oh
[ __ ] you're a lot better than i
remembered right man yeah you know which
was a little odd and then i went back to
some of your old clubs like oh you did
get a lot better i was like oh [ __ ] this
feels really really comfortable and
that's like the stage that i think
everybody wants to get to
right yeah man i appreciate that bro i
just put putting the work in bro for
real that's just [ __ ] nuts i'm a
little jealous dude i'm a little envious
like hey bro but you but you're already
having the question of getting back on
stage bro and when you do i want to i
want to pull up but like
bomb no i'm not sure not
hey write notes yeah
yeah to work bro because because then we
can help each other out you know what i
mean like when i'm on stage you could
have tags with me or whatever bro but
that'd be hella cool to be in that
process with you i know knows i think
you're doing great like it's it's hard
like i'm not that i don't
scrutinize stand up like that that much
like i always say different strokes for
different folks right yeah i'm just
saying tags yeah if there's an idea that
makes your brother you get a little
different yeah but you do it
yeah he could kill me i'm kidding
he's have you ever met him who brendan's
shop no dog his hand is literally like
the size of this [ __ ] cushion oh word
i shook his hand i was like you got a
baseball bit on bro like what the [ __ ]
is it because he was a former top 10 ufc
heavyweight oh [ __ ] yeah he's [ __ ]
huge so a lot of people may talk a lot
of [ __ ] about him you would never say
that to his face he could kill you yeah
if he wanted to he could literally smash
her [ __ ] face it dude yeah okay well
oh uh go check out his latest special
yeah
go check it out please
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast pursue your
dreams grow out that fro and just be
happy go jewelry everywhere always wear
sunglasses indoors even though you can't
see [ __ ] hey man that's what people say
that they were in the club like can you
see them i can't see [ __ ] but i look
cool doing it
you just [ __ ] made out with a man for
six hours he's like
i had a great breath
if i can't see it's all good baby
let's go you where can they follow you
oh yeah you can follow me on all
platforms at christino sosa
c-r-i-s-t-i-n-o society and i got my
youtube channel up and running and uh
you guys can find me on youtube.com
slash chris
c-r-i-s s-o-s-a and i also have a
patreon you can find that link in my bio
i have a link tree so check me out hit
em up and we'll see you guys next time
genius praying every sunday at 12 p.m
let's go yeah